o cibo é uma síndrome que ocorre quando
existe super crescimento bacteriano de
forma descontrolada no intestino delgado
e esses bichinhos Danados realizam a
fermentação nessa região o que resulta
em inchaço aquela barriga grande mesmo e
retenção de gases uma situação bem
desconfortável você sente um aumento de
pressão abdominal bem cômodo mas não é
só o incômodo em sintomas você também
pode ficar deficiente de nutrientes
importantes Como o ferro e a vitamina
B12 para avaliar se você tem essa
condição você pode fazer um exame de
gases expelidos pela boca ou ainda
análise do microbioma intestinal e
também um exame chamado coprológico
estendido são exam de fezes mais
aprofundados para solucionar isso Você
vai precisar do auxílio de um médico
porque muitas vezes somente a mudança
alimentar não vai resolver é muito
importante consumir menos açúcares e
carboidratos fermentáveis ou seja seria
até interessante você se tornar um
carnívoro por um período limitado de
tempo evitando o consumo de muitos
vegetais e fibras Até resolver o
problema